hey guys dr. Burke here in this video I
want to show you how to fix your eyes
okay especially if you want to re close
up without glasses and it's so funny
because people were what's called
corrective glasses but they don't really
correct anything they basically make
your eyes dependent on the glasses and
you need a stronger prescription so
here's here's some a little Natta me you
have the eye structure right here you
have the the clear part which is the
cornea right here the light comes in
here and then iris that's the colored
part like either you have blue eyes you
have green eyes you have brown eyes and
what happens it hits this lens right
here and it's really the combination of
the cornea but mostly the lens the shape
of the lens which which allows you to
see focus in on something either far or
near and what controls the lens is a
little muscle called a ciliary muscle ok
the ciliary muscle so really the shape
of the lens is controlled by this one
muscle right here when that muscle
contracts you're able to see very close
up alright so if you can't see close up
we have a problem with that contraction
it's maybe too contracted but when your
muscle when that muscle relaxes you're
able to see very very far away so we
have this alternating contraction
relaxation all the time when you're
seeing very far and very very near so I
have a question for you what do you
spend most the time doing looking close
up or very far away I mean when's the
last time you looked at a cloud or a
tree or a bird or in the distance
probably a long time right so what
happens if you contract that muscle 24/7
or you find a computer or a cell phone
or the internet I mean constantly REI
pad
this lens is going to become atrophied
to the point where it's not going to
work anymore so you need glasses
especially watch these kids coming up
they don't go outside anymore they don't
play so here's a real simple thing to do
get outside go for a walk but don't read
yourself or when you're walking go just
look at stuff in the distance spend
about 40 minutes or even an hour just
looking far away and focusing in on a
cloud a tree in the distance things
distant object
what that will do that will give your
eyes such a sense of relief it's going
to take the stress out of the eye and
actually reverse this atrophy of the
muscle because it's an inactive muscle
it's not focusing anymore correctly it's
not relaxed see what happens the way you
get a good muscle is you have a
combination of recovery contraction
recovery on/off what's happening in our
eyes is where it's always on all the
time constantly contraction so we have
to relax it and reverse the flow so just
spend a lot more time looking far away
than you do behind the computer if you
work all day and then you don't go
outside and look at different things or
even when you're driving maybe you could
look at things in the far distance but
you're going to have to reverse that
flow if you want to prevent wearing
glasses all right so that's just a
little tip on how you can really get
this muscle very very tone and avoid the
whole cycle of getting stronger and
stronger prescriptions with your glasses
alright hope this helped I will see you
in the next video